this intersection of Margot Morrison and
Tech Street may not
but come April this area's completely
transformed as many
get ready for Spring Carnival Spring
Carnival is a tradition that's been
happening at Carnegie Mellon since the
1920s and is now a four-day weekend
where students get to enjoy many
carnival events rides games food fans
you name it we have it the main events
of Spring Carnival include booth and
budget buggy happens right at this
intersection started out as a soapbox
derby but has since been engineered into
a small torpedo-shaped car where a guy
or girl under five feet under 100 pounds
gets in headfirst and steers the bucket
they act as a baton and are pushed off
the hill free roll around flagstaff hill
reaching speeds up to about 45 miles per
hour and are pushed through the finish
line easily the most competitive sport
we have at Carnegie Mellon and the only
time you see about 95% of our campus
population of an 8 a.m. on a Saturday
morning the other event booths takes
place in the more wood parking lot
many organizations build one or
two-story booths where the public can go
in look around learn interesting facts
and all the booths adhere to an overall
theme the competition is to see who
builds the best overall booth and goes
away with bragging rights